In my 25 years of day trading now,
I've made so many mistakes
that taught me these 15 critical lessons
that I think every trader needs to know.
Understand, I've made nearly $8 million trading
and I've coached tons of students,
including 50 students who are now millionaires,
but I'm breaking down the biggest lessons
that I've learned over time
so that you don't have to learn them a hard way.
Pay attention.
Lesson number one, utilize and embrace new technology.
Okay, technology has changed a lot
over 25 years since I started trading,
but this allows you to learn faster now
and you can learn from anywhere.
For example, I used to have multiple monitors.
Now I literally work off one laptop.
Laptops are amazing.
Now I'm even using my smartphone to trade sometimes.
I mean, frankly, AI is the worst it will ever be.
In the future, it's only getting smarter and smarter,
so I encourage you to embrace it now.
Use AI in your daily life.
I mean, use ChatGPT, use OpenAI, use Grok.
XGPT, for example, is filtering all of my lessons,
all of my patterns,
and putting it into one compact email every single day,
but that's just one example.
I think AI will actually probably cure cancer
in the future too.
Who knows what's possible,
but embrace these technology
because you'll get big data crunched even faster
and in a trader sense, that's very important.
Also, there's many different websites like Barron's,
like the Wall Street Journal, like MarketWatch.
That's good for major market news.
I check CNBC.com sometimes just for looking at
what the Fed is doing
because the Fed can impact the overall market.
Never forget three out of four stocks
follow the overall market.
So I'm using lots of different technology,
lots of different sources,
and I'm trying to get a better grasp
of what's going on in the market.
Obviously, I've been trading 25 years now,
teaching for 15 years.
The markets have changed a lot
and they're gonna continue to change,
but understand several lessons later on in this video,
they're gonna help you trade in today's world.
It's very important to always be adapting to the market.
You don't wanna just sit on lessons
that you learned a decade ago
and then they don't really apply here.
So all of these lessons are made for you in today's world.
Lesson number two, great success takes time.
Rome wasn't built in a day.
Don't roll your eyes, okay?
You need to hear this.
It is a marathon and not a sprint.
My own millions and my now 50 millionaire students,
they took years to achieve.
I wish someone had told me these lessons in the beginning.
This is why I got started of being a teacher.
For example, when I was running my hedge fund,
I met with this one investor
who didn't end up investing with me,
but he shared a very valuable lesson with me
and he made me feel like crap in the moment
where he said, I'm not gonna invest in your fund.
You're not scarred.
And I was like, what are you talking about old man?
I have this great track record.
I've made so much money.
And this was the only one I made like 2 million
at the time I was very cocky.
I didn't have the proper perspective.
And he said, I love your strategy.
I love your passion, but you're not scarred yet.
In the moment, I was like, what are you talking about?
After I lost a million dollars on Cygnus E transactions
and I had a really nasty scar from that,
although it taught me to cut losses quickly,
I then understood why he wouldn't invest in me
because I hadn't developed risk management yet.
I wasn't scarred.
So even though I knew how to profit,
I didn't know how to lose properly.
And that was just one example,
but I did not know where I was in my journey
because that man, and I think he was like in his 60s
or 70s, he had a lot more experience
and he knew exactly where I was in my journey.
So for me, I now recognize the importance of his advice.
Back then, I had no idea.
I thought he was just a crazy old man.
Lesson number three, focus on trading small at first
and survive your learning curve.
Myself, I made too much money in the beginning,
but I was lucky.
I'm like Forrest Gump.
I got started right away.
There was a mania and I made a million dollars.
That actually held me back my entire trading career
because I had too much success in the beginning.
If you now look at my 50 millionaire students,
none of them have too much success in the beginning.
Why?
Because they're so focused on studying, trading small,
building the proper foundation.
Your initial profit and loss is irrelevant in the long run.
In fact, it's actually counterintuitive.
If you make too much money too quickly
and you get too cocky,
it holds you back like it did for me,
but you need that foundation of knowledge
like how to pick the right stocks,
what are the best setups to look for,
and most importantly, knowing how to minimize losses
and how to cut losses.
You don't need to let a small mistake
turn into a potential disaster.
That can really hold you back
because I know a lot of traders,
they lose 20, 30, 40, 50, 70% of their account.
And even though they might be able to make it back,
it holds them back for a while.
Mentally, they're in pain.
Mentally, they're screwed up.
You don't wanna take those big losses.
It's very difficult to get back on your momentum track.
So I have lots of one, two, 3% losses these days.
A lot of my top students do.
You might be surprised,
but a lot of my top students are only winning 40, 50,
55% of the time.
Not 70, 80, 90% of the time, like most people think.
Why?
Because they're wrong a lot while they're testing,
but their losses are much smaller compared to their gains
so their account rises.
I'll talk more about that in a future lesson,
but understand right now,
I'm refocusing the content on my channel
to cover this more foundational day trading knowledge
that is relevant today
because I know you don't think that the foundation matters.
It does.
All great traders started somewhere.
For example, if you only have $1,000 to trade,
definitely watch my video on how to start trading
with only $1,000 and exactly what I would do
and my video on how to trade stocks with zero experience.
You need this foundation.
It's good to review the basics.
Getting back to the lessons, lesson number four,
I really want you to focus on lesser known niches, okay?
Especially when starting out,
focusing on smaller niches like micro caps and small caps,
there might be less money overall to make.
Everyone wants to trade Tesla and Amazon,
the biggest companies and Forex,
but you have more edge and opportunity
to excel in these small niches.
It's very hard to be big traders at their big games.
I wouldn't trade Forex at all.
You actually have no edge whatsoever.
And yet Forex, why?
Because it's the most liquid,
the most popular trading industry in the world.
So you're competing against billionaires.
Guess what?
If you're playing basketball,
you don't want to play against Michael Jordan
or Kobe Bryant or LeBron James.
You want to take on players that you can win against.
I don't want to be in the same niche as billionaires
because I have no chance at winning.
They have so much more experience, so much more capital,
so many more technologies.
Average people don't have a chance.
With small caps and micro caps,
my 50 millionaire students prove,
none of us are that smart,
none of us are that great at math,
but because it's such a smaller niche,
the smartest, most well-prepared traders,
the biggest traders, the biggest investors,
they don't care about this quote, small time stuff.
Even Jack Kellogg, my millionaire trader,
a student with $20 million now,
he laughs at some of the setups that I trade.
He's like, why would I trade that setup?
You can only make a few thousand dollars
because now he's so rich.
So I want you to focus on these plays
where you can quote, only make a few thousand dollars.
That's where the edge is, that's where it's easier.
To give a business example, eBay was started
when the founder just wanted to sell Pez dispensers
and eBay turned into a multi-billion dollar business
starting with Pez dispensers.
You don't have to go for home runs.
You don't have to try to make billions.
Start small, focus on niches, and you'll succeed.
Don't worry, I know you're worried right now,
but I'm gonna share all my favorite niches
in a future video.
So be sure to like, comment, and subscribe.
Lesson number five, you'll never be right 100% of the time.
You have to learn to control your losses
when you are wrong, okay?
Any one loss doesn't really matter if you control it.
If you lose, lose, lose,
but you're losing 1%, 2%, 3%, those losses are fine.
They're basically scratches.
On your wins, if you have a single,
which I consider like a five or 10% or a 15 or 20%,
whether it's my student, whether it's myself,
the whole key is growing your accounts.
Personally, I have a lot of one, two, 3% losses.
I'm fine with that.
I've become fine with that.
In the past, when I was worried about being perfect,
like when that old man told me
that I hadn't been scarred yet,
some of my losses were huge
because I didn't wanna take a small loss.
Now I'm completely open to taking a small loss.
The key is keeping your discipline
and your winners being bigger than your losses.
So any one loss doesn't kill your account or your momentum
and your account grows over time.
And understand, just because you lose monetarily
doesn't mean that it's a complete waste.
In fact, you actually learn more from your losses.
When I am wrong and I lose 1%, 2%, 3%,
I just won't trade that setup again.
That's how you learn what not to do.
Your losses actually are your best teachers.
Lesson number six, do not short sell, okay?
I used to make millions of dollars short selling
but times have changed.
And now there's so many short sellers,
the squeezes have become so crazy.
Even pros risk losing six and seven figures
on some of these squeezes.
Even if the company is a scam,
even if it's a junk company,
even if the stock eventually crashes,
newbies have almost no chance
at winning short selling right now.
This is a lesson that I've learned
and I know it's tough and some people say,
oh Tim, you're a trader, you used to short sell,
you taught everyone how to short sell.
Yes, but again, I am a trader, not a traitor.
There's a difference of spelling there
and it's very important.
Traders with a D, adapt.
Traitors, well, they're just evil, okay?
Benedict Arnold included, but I trade and I adapt.
So short selling, yes,
maybe if you have enough experience, enough money,
you can overcome some of these short squeezes.
But lately we're seeing stocks spike from three,
not just from three to 10 when I used to short sell.
Now some of these stocks are spiking three to 20,
three to 50, three to a hundred in a few hours, okay?
And understand as you're short selling,
you can lose much more than you put in.
So you don't just lose all your money,
you can lose multiples of your money.
And then the money doesn't just disappear,
the broker will actually report you to the credit agencies.
Some traders actually declare bankruptcy
so they don't have to pay their debts from short selling.
It is a very, very slippery slope
and it's partially my fault
because I've popularized short selling
small caps and micro caps.
But guess what?
You can adapt.
And the beautiful thing is
because short selling has become so scary for short sellers,
it's become an absolute blessing for longs.
Imagine writing a stock that goes from three to 60
or five to a hundred in a few hours.
You can grow your account very fast
by focusing on the long side.
This is what trading is all about.
Weeding out patterns that don't work
or are too risky or stressful
and partaking in patterns
where there's a ton of opportunity and upside.
So this brings me to lesson number seven.
Do not be afraid to bet bigger on perfect setups, okay?
Small companies, new technologies,
they can go supernova faster than ever before.
Stocks don't just double or triple in a few days
or a few weeks in this market.
They can go up 10, 20, a hundred times
in a few hours or in a few days.
So be open-minded and be willing to dream big
and take action.
But only if you've studied the setups,
only if you're fully prepared.
It's very scary when these stocks go up and down so fast.
I don't want you to think that every stock
is gonna go supernova and keep going up
because the market is very unforgiving on the way down.
This is the business we've chosen.
So I want you to take profits along the way.
Just in the past few weeks,
we've seen several supernovas that have gone up five, 10,
20 times in a few hours.
We saw CWD, we saw OCTO, we saw QMMM.
Just the other day, WLDS went from two to 10 in 10 minutes.
I literally was on the phone with my programmer
where having a technical issue with the website.
And while I was on the phone with him,
trying to get a video lesson up,
the stock went from two to 10, literally in 10 minutes.
And I missed it.
Later on in this video, I'm gonna share my lessons
of how to cut losses and how to take profits properly.
So stay tuned.
I'm also sharing my favorite trade setups
in one of my next videos.
All of the videos I'm mentioning
will be linked in the description.
So feel free to click around.
It's all about learning.
And if any video that I mentioned is not published yet,
subscribe to the channel so you don't miss it.
We're gonna keep creating more and more videos.
Shout out to Carrie, who's helping organize everything.
Lesson number eight, know who to learn from
and who you shouldn't learn from.
This is very important and I learned this the hard way.
Sadly, most people in this industry are fake
or they're just mediocre performers.
They're not gonna really help you achieve much.
So surround yourself with proven winners
like my 50 top students and myself.
My team and I worked very hard.
For example, in the beginning,
when I wasn't teaching just when I was trading,
I was on a bunch of different websites and chat rooms.
A lot of traders would share their entry price.
They would say, oh, this stock looks amazing.
I'm gonna buy this.
And everyone in the chat room or the website
would get very excited.
The stock would go up as everyone bought.
And then for some reason, the chat leader,
the website leader would never say when they were selling.
Why?
Because they were pumping up the stock.
They didn't care when other people were in the stock
or when it was the best time to sell.
They specifically just wanted to pump up the stock.
And there's a lot of websites and chat rooms like this
where it's follow the leader.
I encourage you to never follow anybody's alerts.
I only share my alerts so that you can learn my process
and my mindset.
It's all about becoming self-sufficient.
I talk a lot about my 50 millionaire students.
Yes, they made a lot of money,
but they know their patterns inside and out.
They trade their own process.
They don't need anybody else.
And that I think is the best way to learn
so that you're self-sufficient too.
So be careful, especially when you have a lot of traders
where they're not sharing their losses,
they're not sharing their exits.
They don't really care about anybody else.
That's very dangerous.
So if you wanna learn more from me,
definitely sign up for my newsletter below.
I promise to teach you everything I know
and it's only gonna be good for you, so use it.
Lesson number nine, your mindset dictates your success.
You have to believe in yourself.
You have to stay dedicated, patient, and positive, okay?
There is no time for negativity
and you shouldn't also expect overnight success,
but there's a lot of negative people in your life,
probably on social media.
You have to tune them out.
I know that they'll say that you can achieve amazing success.
They're right, you can achieve overnight success,
but you can achieve anything in the long run.
I've learned that.
50 of my millionaire students have learned that.
So do not be in a rush for millions of dollars overnight.
I just wanna be clear about that.
You're gonna make bad decisions.
A lot of people think that they can do
all of these amazing things overnight
and they want their leverage,
they wanna just get the immediate payoff, don't, okay?
Have perspective, be patient.
The best rewards, the biggest rewards happen over time.
Remember, this is not just about money.
This is about your knowledge and experience
and later that translates into money.
So this is a very difficult lesson for myself
because I'm a very impatient person,
but once I took away these time limits that were self-imposed,
I was actually a much more successful trader
and a much more successful teacher.
Time is actually on your side if you stay dedicated.
Lesson number 10, seasonality and history matter, okay?
It doesn't matter how prepared you are.
You might have studied everything
and you're like, okay, now's the time.
But if you're in a bear market or if the market crashes
or maybe it's a slow season,
it doesn't matter how much you study.
There's not gonna be that many opportunities.
There's not gonna be that much money to be made.
So understand that the market goes through different cycles.
Let me tell you why I go to Italy every summer.
I'm very blessed to have a beautiful villa in Italy
that I go to every single summer.
But why do I go there specifically every summer?
Because the summer is slower,
specifically July and August.
Those are historically the two slowest months of the year,
although lately in this bull market,
it hasn't even been slow.
But usually those two months are slower
and you'll find that a lot of the most successful traders,
the most successful investors in the world,
they take some time off.
This is not a normal nine to five job.
You can take time off.
It's good for your mental stability.
It's fun, it's good to bring your friends and your family.
But at the same time, recognize when the times are slower.
And I actually have a great story
from one of the traders who were out there this past summer.
His name is Joe.
He's made millions of dollars
and he was just chilling, drinking.
And I was like, Joe, Joe, the market's on fire.
And I was still trading
because I'm sometimes a degenerate gambler myself.
I try to teach you,
but I also have lessons to learn myself.
And Joe said, looked at me and he's like,
what are you doing?
I was like, there's so many plays.
And he's like, when I'm back in the US, I'll trade.
Right now I'm taking it easy.
And it was such a good lesson and it still sticks with me.
So understand if the market is slow
or if you just wanna relax, that's okay too.
The market will always be there.
So learn from history, learn from seasonality,
learn from what works best for you too.
Some people will say, Tim,
shouldn't you just trade all the time?
There's so much money to be made.
Yes, but it is also mentally draining.
It's actually very important.
Even if the market is on fire,
sometimes you just need to take a day off, a week off.
I know some traders who take a month off,
even if they're crushing it,
you have to protect your mental health too.
Lesson number 11, be open-minded
to trading all types of assets, okay?
The market has changed, the world has changed,
and we're traders.
So it's okay to trade crypto, NFTs, AI, gold,
anything that can take off and really outperform.
You don't just have to focus on the FAANG stocks
or mutual funds and try to beat the S&P 500,
which spikes what allows the eight to 10% per year.
There's so much upside in a lot of these lesser known
niches, as I always say, but if you're open-minded,
you can participate.
And if you want me to make a video on crypto,
let me know in the comments,
because I'm honestly not sure how many of you
are interested in this,
but I think it might be useful for you.
Lesson number 12, admit when you're wrong
and cut losses quickly.
If you click below, I have a whole video
where literally I talk about cutting losses quickly,
nonstop, that's the only thing I say.
It's so important, because if an investment,
or let's say a relationship is heading
in the wrong direction, cut it, save yourself time
and grief, life is too short.
It's so, so difficult and draining
to be in a bad relationship or in a bad position.
It's not just about the money.
Remember, you have to protect your mental health.
I'll tell you, my biggest loss was Cygnus E-Transactions.
This was a company I believed in, printed home ticketing.
I was right about the technology.
I was wrong about the company.
They went bankrupt and it took several months
to go bankrupt.
And unfortunately, I didn't know about cut losses
quickly back then.
I didn't know about trading liquid stocks.
I actually had restricted shares,
so I couldn't even sell.
And the stock every day would just go lower and lower
because pretty much everyone knew
that they were heading into bankruptcy.
And every day I woke up, I felt so mentally drained
because there was literally nothing I could do
with my restricted stock.
And it was really just a terrible feeling for months.
Then when they finally did go bankrupt, I felt even worse.
And then to make matters even worse,
the new CEO who claimed that he was gonna turn around
the company, he actually bought the company in bankruptcy,
somehow kept all of the same contracts,
and later it became a hundred million dollar plus company.
So I was right about the technology.
In the end, I was right about the company,
and yet I lost over a million dollars.
And that was when I was running a hedge fund.
So half of it was my money.
Half of it was friends and family, which made it even worse.
I never wanna be in that position again.
And to be fair, I never put myself in a position like that.
I don't do restricted stock deals.
I don't take huge positions like that anymore.
I never want that again.
So I can't encourage you enough to cut losses quickly.
Cut losses quickly.
Losses quickly.
Take a 1%, 2%, 3% loss.
It might not be so much fun.
You might be a little frustrated,
but it's not gonna drain your account
and it's not gonna drain your mental capital too.
And I know cutting losses quickly isn't easy.
So how to cut losses quickly is a highly requested video
from my community.
I'm gonna make a video on this.
Watch for it when it publishes.
I know it's gonna help you.
Lesson number 13, take profits into strength.
Do not hodl.
I know hodling has worked in the past with crypto,
but this is a huge mistake because the markets will change
and while investments and niches can spike up huge
in this fast moving world, they can also crash very fast.
Okay, and you don't wanna overstep.
See NFTs as an example.
Everyone was so excited about NFTs.
The NFT prices spiked so quickly
for several months and then they all came crashing down.
And to this day, this was what?
Like two plus years ago now,
to this day I know people who are still holding
onto their NFTs and they don't even know what to do
because the prices are down 98, 99, 100%.
And it's really just a terrible thing.
Like if you bring up the word NFT at any trader gathering,
a lot of traders take it very personally.
You've insulted me.
I always say ride the hype, but never believe it.
I want you to understand that.
It's all fun and games.
By the way, it's great to ride some of these companies up
like Nvidia or Amazon or Tesla.
Big companies are different,
but when you're trading a lot of the hype,
like whether it's a meme coin, whether it's NFTs,
whether it's some of these penny stocks,
there are a lot of OTC bulletin board stocks
that spiked 50, 100, 200 times in the past,
you must sell in the strength.
If you actually look at my own personal trading
over 25 years and you look at a lot of my best trades,
they're not necessarily huge profits,
but they're 1,000, 2,000, 5,000,
sometimes 10 or $20,000, but I sell along the way.
I lock in those profits and I don't look back.
And I really think that's the way to be.
Now, judging from my 50 plus millionaire students,
they're taking profits along the way too.
None of us are hodling and we have all of our profits
in one or two different assets.
That's a very risky way to trade.
And I think it's gonna come back to bite people,
especially when this bull market ends.
Whenever that happens, it's gonna be ugly
for people who are unprepared.
Lesson number 14, always celebrate big wins
and milestones and achievements, okay?
It's easy to say, oh, you should always want more and more.
It's just another day.
But when you actually take the time to celebrate a big win,
it's not only fun, but you're actually subconsciously
training your brain to want more wins and more milestones.
I love taking my millionaire students
to different places around the world
when they hit a million dollars.
When I made my first $100,000 in the stock market,
I took my whole dorm out to dinner.
I was just a freshman in college.
I still remember it to this day.
And I want more $100,000 wins personally,
and I want more millionaire students.
So it's all about motivation.
Celebrate your big wins, thank me later.
Lesson number 15, community matters, okay?
I can't encourage you enough to join our community
and build yourself a community of like-minded individuals.
Not just about money, right?
It's about sharing useful tips, sharing stocks in play,
supporting each other when we lose.
It's really great because trading can get lonely.
And frankly, it's far better to win together.
And it's far easier too.
We're all sharing different ideas.
If you watch MrBeast's channel on YouTube,
part of the reason that he became such a successful YouTuber
is because he says he's part of this community of YouTubers
and they were obsessed with growing their accounts
and creating the best content.
The same holds true with traders.
If you look at my 50 millionaire students now,
we all get together around the world
and we all talk trading and bounce ideas off each other.
And it really helps us.
It's really cool, again, with people who are in
a similar industry and have similar experiences.
You start to get better perspective
and it really helps you not just make more money,
but it also helps with the mental aspect.
If you want to join our community,
there's a link in the description.
Just be positive, be dedicated,
and we're all in this together.
That's it for today.
Good luck and I'll see you in the next video.